halt free also ich kann hier atmen et
cetera und hier bin ich dann wieder
unter wasser
[Musik]
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft fakes endlich wieder
nach zwei monaten oder gefühlten zwei
millionen 1000 jahren
ihr habt mir wieder fleißig fix zugesagt
wie sie halt fleißig zugesendet und ich
hab die so verarbeitet und habe da die
besten rausgefiltert die ich noch nicht
vorgestellt habe wie immer
falls die fans in irgend einem anderen
video schon fahren bzw die auf irgend
einem anderen wege schon kennengelernt
habt also halt schon genau wisst was ich
mir vorstelle beispiel zwar sozusagen
halt dann könnt ihr einfach wegschalten
oder mir bessere facts per e mail an
konkreter gmail.com schreiben wo er mir
allgemeinheit facts und schreiben können
ich würde sagen direkt mit dem ersten
effekt und zwar von wie twins arbeite
hey du hast da machen wir das problem
ihr kennt es nichts bauen immer wenn ich
die responder ist brauche ich sehr viele
tiere um es euch einfach mehr zu
veranschaulichen macht die map meistens
so nicht so einfach so ich mache diesen
papieren hin sondern auch jetzt regnet
ich mach das mal kurz aus sondern macht
das meistens so ein bisschen schöner
macht dann von allen tieren auch mehr
und will die dann auch nachher wieder
umbringen ich hab das damals immer mein
schwert gemacht allerdings im neuesten
snapshot wo drin diese ganze die das
ganze video spielt in dem neuesten
snapshot wie aus einem guss nicht snap
chat snapshot das lab gibt es einen
befehl und zwar / kill also schrägstrich
kill und wenn man unterdrückt tötet man
alle lebenden lebewesen und auch sich
selbst also das ist ein bisschen traurig
dass ich mich selbst dabei auch töten
aber naja man kann damit auf jeden fall
jede x-beliebige person töten im
multiplayer konnte ich nicht testen weil
ich keinen eigenen server habe und auf
anderen servern keine rechte habe aber
ich würde mal gruppe sagen dass es dort
nicht funktioniert wenn es wenig besser
bist dann schreib deine kommentare da
können die anderen leute dass da auch
nachlesen
und natürlich sagen weil es auf jeden
fall erste effekt und den werde ich auf
jeden fall in zukunft ein bisschen öfter
nach den videos an wänden kommen wir nun
zum zweiten effekt und zwar behandelt
dieser effekt eine tür und wasser was
kann das wohl zu bedeuten haben ich weiß
es nicht ich wusste selbst nicht bis vor
kurzem beziehungsweise ich wusste schon
aber ich hab's immer wieder verdrängt
und mir ist aufgefallen dass das sehr
sehr viele leute noch nicht wussten war
dass einer unter ein video mal runter
geschrieben hat und arbeiten so als ob
man das geht doch gar nicht so richtig
so wie im film so he was hast du da mal
so richtig komisch
ihr kennt es ja ruhig blut an basta und
irgendwann steht man halt wenn man
allerdings irgendwie nicht mehr aus dem
wasser raus kommt aber man hat irgendwie
zum beispiel alles dabei ganz blödes
beispiel jetzt ihr wart gerade baum
abfällen und dann fällt der firma ein
wasserloch nun seit irgendwo unter
wasser und der kommt nicht raus weil
über euch jetzt ob sie die art und das
wird jahre dauern und die würde der
trinken aber ihr habt halt holz dabei
dann würde ich mir ganz schnell crafting
table machen und dem crafting table
steine wurden dort weil die könnt ihr
einfach hinsetzen und hinter dieser
wurden dort ist dann ein bereich wo
quasi kein wasser durchkommt also auch
wenn ihr die tür aufmacht ist in diesem
bereich wenn ich eine tür setzte hinter
dieser tür beziehungsweise wenn ich die
tür aufmache ist hier komplett halt free
also ich kann hier atmen et cetera und
hier bin ich dann wieder unter wasser
das funktioniert ich hab das extra 3
tief gemacht wenn ich das zwei tief
gemacht hätte ich kann ich das auch mal
ganz kurz ihr zeigen wenn ich jetzt eine
tür darauf setzen würde dann wirds halt
von oben raus gehen also da ist keine
wasserschicht dann mehr drüber
das ist halt so hoch wie die tür ist
also zwei blöcke können man dann atmen
das ist denke ich ein ganz cool effect
den mit sicherheit einige zwar schon
kennen aber noch nie so wirklich mal
genutzt haben also wirklich in dieser
ertrinken für farben kommen wir nun zu
einem fact woran ich wirklich nie
gedacht hätte wie man auch so was kommen
kann und zwar habe ich einfach mal ihr
seht es ich hab hier so'n teppiche
hingelegt ich mache jetzt mal ganz
korrekt damit ihr seht was darunter ist
da drunter ist überall gras also
normalerweise wenn ich jetzt einen
scharf darauf setzte dann frisst es nach
der zeit dieses gras weil
das schaf ja wenn das geschäft wurde muß
es gras essen damit dass wieder neue
wurde produzieren kann
jetzt ist es allerdings so wenig darüber
teppich habe nein das ist nicht
unendlich dass wir immer noch gefressen
allerdings geht der teppich dabei nicht
kaputt ich kann mich jetzt einfach mal
die schafe hierhin zu bauen jetzt warten
wir bis 1 hier irgendwie fressen sollte
der zwischenzeit galerien kleinen witz
erzählen
das kann ich euch da sie die schafe
kommen mir vor als ob dir irgendwie auch
zu hören wollen
diese fressen mir fällt gar kein witz
ein
ich habe immer gute witze der kommentare
dass er nicht mal braucht ich kenne ich
fast gar keine witze mehr was ist grauen
kann telefonieren ein elefant okay ich
hatte glaube ich etwas gefressen
oder war das hier ja genau da war das
und da ist jetzt nämlich der teppich ihr
hat gesehen dass teppich war noch da
allerdings das gras darunter ist kein
gras mehr an den anderen seiten hier ist
noch gras ich kann immer wieder gras
hinsetzen vielleicht noch mal hier wurde
etwas gefressen jetzt gesehen ist kaputt
gegangen
allerdings war der teppich noch drauf
also wenn ihr da irgendwie so eine
grünfläche haben wollten wir wollen
nicht dass sie so zerstückelt aussieht
macht irgendwie einfach grünen teppich
drauf oder ich weiß nicht welche teppich
gibt sondern es gibt sogar den hier
sieht sogar noch mehr auf wie gras also
wenn ihr das einfach so haben wollt dann
macht euch einfach peppig und dann sieht
das ganze so aus als wenn das nicht
kaputt geht so wie hier kommen wir nun
zum fun fake beziehungsweise zu dem
viereck das ist ja eigentlich immer nie
so einfach wird jeder mal zwar habe ich
gelacht
er war ja so wird sich diesmal der fun
fact die und zwar erkennt es bestimmt
hey ich lebe in einem bio oben und ich
habe einfach nur
wird also nur birken darmstadt oder hey
ich lebe in schnee und haben dieses plus
wurde oder ich leben im dschungel und
ich will hier raus welchen stapel
ich habe noch dunkel wird man will aber
auch gut also man will dass hier
beziehungsweise das ganz normale hier
weil man daraus gegen ein haus bauen
möchte
das geht ganz einfach entweder man läuft
halt richtig weit oder es ist ein ganz
ganz simpler trick also ich mache das
jetzt mal alles hier verarbeitet das
weiter man kann sich einfach gut zu
machen also jetzt ein bisschen wird aus
diesen verschiedenen sachen und die
boote sind ja immer gleich das wäre
übrigens schaut dann wenn du coolere
boote machen willst da macht auch das
man aus diesen quellen bot mir auch
hände bekommt aus dem dunklen dunkle
boote und aus den hier irgendwie
sämtliche boote dass wir auf jeden fall
heftigkeit man bekommt hat immer die
gleichen boot man kann die dann hier
einfach rein setzen so ich setzte jetzt
hier einfach mal so ich kann ja immer
noch ein zweites so kleines ach scheiße
ich bin dem creative mord man dann
manchmal eben keyboard 0
so wenn ich jetzt ein boot ihre einsätze
das war jetzt das boot was sich zum
beispiel aus dem gut gemacht haben sie
dabei genau so aus wie ein auto boot
kann ich jetzt kaputt machen
bekomme ich jetzt im boot wenn ich aber
dass noch mal was im moment sehe ich das
jetzt komplett kaputt machen und
beispielsweise gegen eine wand gegen
fahre da muss ich jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz hier moment raus ich mach das mal
dazu mit anderen boot so man kann bot er
nicht mehr kaputt machen zu wollen
wenn ich gegen eine wand fahre bekomme
ich immer dieses raus also ich bekomme
immer auch mit raus das ist einfach weil
die ganzen boote gleich sind und bei den
boden noch nicht diese unterscheidung da
war es war ja auch damals so dass man
aus dem virtual beispielsweise so ganz
normales ganz normale harfst apps machen
konnte
dass es trotzdem kontrollieren ganz
normale hochzeit machen konnte aber
mittlerweile warte ich gemerkt ein gate
mittlerweile gibt es daher auch die
verschiedensten herbst selbst hier
moment wo haben wir sie denn da es gibt
das plus mit bird watching mutter katia
slap und bleibt also das wird
wahrscheinlich dann in zukunft weil es
jetzt jetzt ja auch schon mit treppen
gibt und dieses labs und die sind
darauf drückt teilen jetzt denke ich in
zukunft auch mit boten geben und allen
anderen sachen und vielleicht auch mal
mit meinen dass man mein cards werden
kann und dass man boote färben kann das
soll jetzt alles mal geben
find ich ganz cool also wenn ihr einfach
5 von diesem wird und daraus ein boot
macht und dann mit gegen die wand fährt
bekommt ihr immer drei raus also es war
ein schlechter tausch ist jetzt sind
nicht so fünf reinboth machen und fünf
wieder rausbekommen auch gut aber es ist
auf jeden fall eine gute möglichkeit um
das umzuwandeln
wenn man keine august baumühlner gegend
habt das war's dann auch schon wieder
mit perfect folge wenn es euch gefallen
hat was bitte eine bewertung oder wenn
es euch nicht gefallen hat dann lasst
eure bewertung gab er dann eine negative
schreibt mir mal was euch gut gefällt
was euch nicht gefällt dann auch
eventuell was ich morgen für ein video
hochladen könnte und dann will ich sagen
euch noch einen schönen tag per e-mail
schreiben und tschüss